let's read this first story from the
buffalo news
authorities investigating a retired
federal agent knew of buffalo mass
shooting plans in advance
they're actually wondering
if this dude should be charged as an
accomplice what they're basically saying
is that in this dis i think was in the
discord
that uh the um i'm sorry the uh here we
go
the the perpetrator shared the
information with six individuals one of
which was a retired uh federal agent
they say agents from the fbi are in the
process of tracking down and
interviewing the six people including
the retired agent and attempting to
determine if if any of them should be
charged as accomplices the two sources
with close knowledge of the probe told
the buffalo news the two sources did not
identify the agent by name and could not
confirm what agency he worked for
i got i just got to start off by saying
sometimes there are racist former
federal agents sometimes people who are
criminals work for different departments
or maybe this guy was in a discord and
did not see any of this information and
that's why he didn't report it we don't
know but the reason i want to i want to
lead with this is because there's a lot
of questions around all of these it's
becoming particularly prominent to see
on twitter and other platforms where
people are questioning how these things
can actually happen like how is it you
know with euvaldi a guy
two days after his 18th birthday he gets
one of the best most expensive rifles
possible what was his training how could
he have afforded he was being made fun
of for being uh you know poor now all of
a sudden
you know so people question this stuff i
think there are simple solutions simple
answers to a lot of these things but i
do think
we could not debunk that truly and
honestly we can cast doubt onto these
theories but i think it's interesting so
i don't know what do you guys think
about this the uh the the potential
federal agent i should ask you brian as
as you are former former former fed
maybe current
you just like current fed
yeah got it all right
yeah look there are there are bad apples
in every bunch aren't there and whether
this guy was knowledgeable and actually
ignored his own training which is these
folks especially bureau guys they know
absolutely the signs the flags and when
and where to report those so
he should have a very special sensitive
tripwires at the point and the fact that
he didn't do what he should have is
really odd and frankly disconcerting
because it it doesn't make sense
interesting some people were so i can't
confirm a lot of what people are posting
in these stories but some people are
saying that apparently these guys might
have been in uvalde and buffalo in the
same discords or that the people egging
them on may have been in the same same
discords
[Music]
i don't know if you go back all the way
to columbine
and you look at uh the investigation
into that
even even uh
dylan clayblot i think his name was i
forget
thank you but even his his family said
you know he spent a lot of time in the
garage we always heard these loud noises
he was always blowing things up um this
is kind of similar in the sense that
there are a lot of warning signs right
like clearly he's telling people just
like the guy in texas you know told
people he told that girl who he tagged
on social media in la like i'm gonna do
this um i mean if that isn't a sign that
there is some clear mental problem that
there's this very blatant cry for help
there's there's almost the desire to
attract attention
before the fact and i think right now
the conversation as it should be is you
know what else can we do but i think
what we're starting to see now is well
actually
there really isn't a need necessarily
for more laws or more sort of
bureaucratic steps it's just actually to
execute what the things that we were
supposed to do more thoughtfully more
consistently whether it's at the schools
uh you know making sure doors are shut
for people say if you're a parent or
you're a loved one or you're a neighbor
and you start seeing this stuff
raise the flag do the things that we all
know to that work right so i don't know
in this case as we learn more that we
really should have an additional layer
of
laws or whatnot it's really just making
sure that we what we do and you know
have on the books just execute that more
thoughtfully more consistently yeah and
i'll tell you that this issue of
training that's one that i think is
really odd on this with this fellow
because he was so young there is no
he just got this gun it's not a light
weapon to work with so some degree of
training exposure where did he get that
that's one of the things that i have
been looking at and looking for yeah so
uh
when someone when people are pointing
out this gun with taxes and shipping and
everything was two grand
you know a lot of people said how could
a guy who works at wendy's and is under
18 afford that because you'd have to uh
i mean
save up for how long i mean i suppose if
he's living with his mom he's not paying
anything but then was apparently he got
to a fight with his grandma or something
over a phone bill so he i mean maybe he
really just saved up this money and then
it's it actually is it could be quite
simple a credit card
you turn 18 you get a credit card if
you've got no bad credit you might get a
couple grand on a credit card yeah but
that's the time frame
so i'm not sure if this is correct i
don't know if you guys know you guys
could fact check me but it was it was
two days after his 18th birthday
can i so he ordered the gun online
and then maybe a week in advance it got
shipped in then he went there and picked
it up and then the next day maybe i mean
it's all possible i don't want to say
it's not not i don't think it's
impossible but
it is kind of like did he really
plan it out meticulously as he did i
suppose right that sounds like he'd been
planning it for a while if he if he
organized it so that the gun had arrived
after he turned 18 and everything was
right then it sounded like he'd been
planning it well let me add so this
issue of planning so in the intelligence
community particularly with terror
attacks we know that there is a planning
process and along that process you end
up finding
ways to intervene they they slip up they
make mistakes there are little warning
signs and from an intel perspective
that's what you look for to stop those
attacks so i think again we're going to
see the more investigative work that
gets done there are those little pops
and flags that are going to we're going
to see retroactively be like we should
have seen that or somebody did see that
and they didn't do something and i think
that's where we're going to start really
making a difference when we see these
horrible events happen we learn from
them that's how we stop the next one
it's going to change the next attack's
going to change but that's what we learn
yeah you basically what you were just
saying before
uh to add on to that
when i look at these these incidents i
think one of the problems we have is
that we think there's a solution and
maybe there is i'm not saying we
shouldn't try and figure something out
but i wonder if when you know people are
saying we need armed teachers and i'm
like well you know i think if people
were armed in general we'd
we'd probably be better off but i don't
know if that solves the problem of a
deranged young person who plans this
thing out if this dude really did plan
it out as extensively as he did and
seemingly he did because he ordered it
in advance waited until his 18th
birthday saved him money or got a credit
card who knows what he did but he
planned it
then
i don't i don't think
i'll put it this way you you mentioned
something before the show you said we
got to be right 100 out of 100 times
because at one time you aren't is when
they get you
so we can we can plan we can be like
okay how about armed teachers and then
the kid just the next the next person
makes a plan to accommodate for arms
teachers i think the issue is that we've
got
a cultural and and a mental illness
problem
i think that you know i know a lot of
conservatives say mental illness problem
but you look at the medication these
kids are on and we have a fatherlessness
problem
it's cultural and it's and it's
multifaceted amen everybody just wants
this singular solution they're like we
either ban the guns or you know i'm the
teachers and i'm like that's not going
to solve what's going on well i think
and when it comes to the the government
stepping in
you know
this kid is cutting himself
right he's made a lot of threats where's
child protective services and and all
i'm going to say is i don't even have
it's not even a question it's more just
an observation but child protective
services were shown up to people's
parent to parents house where they
refused to vaccinate their kids within
hours right then the height of the
pandemic of covid
a child protective services was stepping
in
swiftly so it's just kind of bizarre
that the same government services that
we are looking to protect children in
the case that the parents are not doing
their job
seem to be kind of absent when this is a
very clear case of a kid who is troubled
who is abusive who is uh i mean
if you're 17 and you're cutting yourself
you're cutting your face repeatedly
there i mean how much more of a red flag
law do we need to say this kid is not
but boy if he had said my parents won't
get me vaccinated holy crap the child
protective services would have been
there within minutes what if he says my
parents won't let me get my adderall
prescription filled will child
protective services come and take him
will they side with him because he needs
his adderall or will they side with a
parent because it's unconscionable to
give a 14 year old adderall my parents
won't let me choose my pronoun yeah holy
how would they have swept in and said
the abuse you're creating to this child
so my the reason why i'm bringing this
up is is not to dump on people who are
failing at their job but if you're
turning to the government for a solution
i don't think you're going to have any
solution that works not in this case
it's it's it's like state of mind the
government is not good at solving state
of mind you need like a spiritual leader
or something or something like that i
think we are in a culture war for a
reason we have very serious cultural
problems now it's cool to see that the
left and right are unified in their
disdain for the police over this one but
when you look at how the left has been
approaching basically everything
i can say
it feels to me the reason moderates and
conservatives are kind of united you've
got post-liberal libertarian centrists
and conservatives all sort of in
agreement because they're actually
addressing facts and issues the left
isn't
you know when it comes to issues of
these shootings they say background
checks i said yesterday okay we have
those oh ban the ar-15 okay what about
an ak what about an m1a what about any
other gun i mean so many they're just
not saying anything but they're getting
really really mad
you know so so i look at the the the
deep cultural issues and i'm and i'm
sorry if i'm not going to take a
liberal's word for it because they
believe jesse smallette and now we have
this tweet going viral from another fake
account claiming that governor abbott
sent a rep to this guy's house
telling him that if you know we'll pay
you to stand with the governor
and if you don't we'll criminally charge
you or something it's the most
ridiculous made up fake story probably
by a 12 year old
walking castro's tweeting let me know if
you need any help pulitzer winning
journalists are all tweeting it out like
i can't believe this is happening uh
christopher titus the comedian verified
he's like abbott is done it's like dude
boomers i mean i want to say boomer but
they're not boomers they're like 35
years old and twitter hasn't taken it
down twitter hasn't flagged it right as
misinformation or false
um yeah
but forgive me if i say the people who
believe jesus millette i'm not going to
take political advice from it's just
never going to happen yeah
maybe a lack of critical thinking
because i think they're still getting
facts that's just not right they're
wrong facts whatever that means well
then they're not facts yeah like that
the ar means assault rifle for instance
and then they think ban
ban ar you're not gonna have any more
assault rifles so even if you look at
this i think from the most hopeful
perspective people need control and when
you have a moment like this everything
feels out of control so you're gonna
gravitate to the thing that makes you
feel best and most comfortable and it's
ar-15 okay that's the bad thing that we
all need to focus our energy on doesn't
matter the nuance or the facts it's just
enough people in the moment of hysteria
say that's the bad thing there's the one
silver bullet solution focus on it and
that's just not true you're bringing up
the very correct points is this is
multi-faceted maybe we have a medicine
issue or so
the mental health concern we have a lack
of a father we have a lack of support in
the family there are so many different
pieces to each of these kinds of of
horrific
shootings that to stop and really ask
tough questions
not happening we just want the one
silver bullet solution thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there